so today Microsoft announced that
windows blue will be coming out this
year now this leads some people to think
that they're going to be going to a
yearly iteration so the next windows
will it will be 8.1 won't be windows 9
they do have some good news is that
Windows has gone when those eight has
sold 100 million licenses which is on
park windows seven after about six
months that's good news yeah I'm right
yeah it's good for I can't find my start
button by the way yeah a lot of people
are kind of there hoping than 8.1 will
have a start button which was pulled
from windows 8 now you got all this
swipey stuff just do this a lot this
week we are talking about the Fitbit
flex whoo it's basically an activity
tracker with an accelerometer in it that
measures your movement and uses that to
give you a better picture of your
overall activity and health it's a
really super wearable tracker which i
think is one of the most important
things it's not the most important thing
in an activity tracker it's very slim at
a low profile with a really nice secure
clasp so that you know it doesn't get
hung on things like this this job on
contend to do it's also waterproof so
you can or at least waterproof enough so
you can wear it in the shower and it's
got a Bluetooth 4.0 connection so it
uses basically low-power bluetooth to
send data to your phone or to a little
dongle you can plug into your computer
and you don't have to use the smartphone
app you can tap it to see how far along
towards your step goal you are you can
also tap it to send it into sleep mode
at night so when it's time to conk out
just tap the device five times before
you go to bed and it goes into sleep
tracking mode then in the morning when
you're ready to wake up it'll vibrate so
that it can wake you up without waking
up whoever you're sleeping with one of
the nice little metrics it shows you is
how many minutes you've been active
every day so you can see like you know
okay I was really too sedentary today so
so my is this active this count steadily
go walking
get my groove on slave to the rhythm
just ignore him